we're not afraid chanted thousands of
people on the streets of havana
protests like this one happened across
the country expressing frustration over
pandemic restrictions
and the worsening economic crisis on the
island nation
we are here for the repression because
they are killing us with hunger the
houses are falling and we have no homes
they have the money to build hotels
while letting us go hungry
the past year and a half has been
difficult for cuba's economy
as the pandemic has had a devastating
impact on the tourism sector
the country was forced to carry out
major economic reform
in the past week the amount of
covenanting infections rose sharply
in the province of matanzas where
hospitals are struggling to cope
doctors say they are in desperate need
of oxygen and vets to treat patients
president miguel diacanel blamed the u.s
embargo for the situation
and ask government supporters to take to
the streets
we are not going to admit that any
counter-revolutionary mercenary
sold out to the government of the united
states sold out to the empire receiving
money from the agencies
allowing themselves to be carried away
by all these strategies of ideological
subversion
to provoke destabilization in our
country there will be a revolutionary
response
we call upon all the revolutionaries of
the country all the communists
to take to the streets to any of the
places where these provocations are
going to take place
today from now on and in the following
days
security forces arrived soon after the
protest started
people were arrested and some clashes
broke out between pro
and anti-government demonstrators state
security beat me and my daughter
a minor they beat us because we were
walking down the streets
protests like this one are uncommon in
cuba this is the biggest one to take
place since 1994
during what is known as the special
period right after the fall of the
soviet union
for many they're an example of the
changing times on the caribbean nation
and how many are no longer afraid to
speak up
teresa